Is he running or is he just running?
Welcome to Unfiltered. I'm S.E. Cupp.
Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis
is presumed
to be mounting a run for president
but lately
it seems more like he's
just running from Florida.
Florida is facing several crises
at the moment.
Last week's One in a thousand year
weather event saw severe flooding
throughout the southern part of the state
and also resulted in a gas shortage.
But the Santos was two states
away on Wednesday
talking to South Carolina voters
about fighting wokeness last week.
While many parts of Florida
were underwater
and DeSantis
declared a state of emergency
for Broward County.
He went to Ohio to continue
to promote his book
that caught the eye of Donald Trump Jr,
who dinged the governor
for traveling quote,
instead of taking care of the people
suffering in his state.
While Democratic State
Senator Chevron
Jones called it
disgraceful
and telling about his priorities,
he has failed as a leader.
Jones said it's unclear whether DeSantis
his national book tour is irking
Florida voters.
But polling has former
President Donald Trump
increasing his lead over
DeSantis in a hypothetical matchup
in their home state and nationally.
DeSantis this culture war on Disney
also seems to be doing him no favors.
Fellow Republicans
are even calling it out.
Chris Christie,
the former New Jersey governor,
says DeSantis is being outfoxed
by Disney chief Bob Iger.
That's not the guy
I want sitting across from Chinese
President Xi Jinping
or Russian
President Vladimir Putin
trying to resolve
what's happening in Ukraine.
If you can't see around a corner
that Bob Iger creates for you,
I mean, I don't think
that's very imposing, said Christie.
He also said
telling private corporations
what to do isn't very conservative.
And Fox Business host
Larry Kudlow warned
the dissenters was close
to making a fool of himself
with his Walt Disney obsession.
Indeed, DeSantis
even suggested putting a prison next
to Disney for some reason.
These recent missteps really undercut
DeSantis, his own heavily crafted persona
and presumed Cabinet campaign platform,
which is that
he stays above the fray out of the drama
and is hard at work for Florida.
Remember these quotes
last month
as Trump was facing
an indictment for his role
in the handling of hush money
payments to Sanders
bragged, The way we run the government,
I think, is no daily drama
focused on the big picture
and put points on the board.
When asked about Trump's
nicknames for him,
he insisted,
It's not important for me
to be fighting
with people on social media.
It's not accomplishing anything for
the people I represent,
but I'm betting floods and
gas shortages are important
to the people he represents.
But no matter
He also insisted
he wouldn't
get involved
in some manufactured circus
like Trump's indictment.
But one could certainly argue
that his foolish war on Disney
is just that
a manufactured circus of his own making.
I'm not sure
what exactly de Santos is doing,
but when it comes to
his presidential prospects,
it isn't working.
For a guy who is no drama
and fighting for Florida,
he certainly seems to be
courting the drama
and leaving Floridians behind
the cherry on top
Trump is racking up the endorsements
from Republican lawmakers
in their home state.
That's it for me. See you next week.